Tom how are you I am well Dan how are
you I'm good we're just reminiscing
about Fenway like the first time you see
it I can't imagine what a pitcher thinks
when they walk in there and because that
Green Monster it feels like it grows it
gets closer to you as as you see it for
the first time that recalls the classic
line from Bill Lee of course the nutty
left-hander from the 70s we first saw
Fenway
there's obviously poor game batting
practice he said wait a second do they
leave that thing there for the game yeah
what is the ideal Stadium for baseball
now I still love Camden Yards I listen I
you can't beat the history of family
ever again I separate those out but
terms of modern convenes and the way
people watching game I like a man yard
it looks like it's been around forever
but it's got all about our convenes and
what you're seeing a lot of teams do now
Dan is taking out seats and opening up
these party areas because that's the way
people watch a game they watch it you
know like they're at a club or something
where they're not exactly locked into
every pitch tonight keeping score I want
to chat with their buddies you know I
have an adult beverage and when
something happens they turn out and
watch the game so you're seeing these
open areas and they've been really
popular summarize the first month of the
season if you were given the audience
the Cliff Notes version where would you
start too many strikeouts besides the
weather was absolutely terrible
there's nothing to do about strikeouts
but it's got up no I think it's 11 12
consecutive years and usually baseball
self-corrects itself I don't see
anything on the horizon that would stem
the tide of strikeouts in the game today
and he's thrown asked the question how
much is too much no you know I did the
game last night between the Yankees and
the asterism more than half the house in
the game or strikeouts and here an
Astros fan you're watching your team bat
at the end of the game the last 11
batters came to the plate eight of them
struck out against three different
pitchers and that's the game that we
have now it started kated I'll hold on
obviously but you're not seeing rallies
you know the rally is dead teams know
it's just too hard to string together
hits so they swing for the fences once
in a while Gary Sanchez did last night
they get it
you have to live with all these
strikeouts in between and a parade of
researchers to go out and get him have
you ever seen a pitcher punched himself
or smack himself after giving up a home
run as we had last night when Sanchez
went EEP no not what's it happened like
first of all I can't believe that they
chose the pitch to Gary Sanchez in that
spot first base open you main case that
Sanchez is the best ball hitter Yankee
lineup there's no way I'm pitching
dammit I'm the way I'm making a picture
around scenario if you watch the replays
Brian McCann actually Isis was in the
strike zone and Giles said he was trying
to get him out in the strike zone all of
that wasn't crazy but punching yourself
is even crazier than that talking to Tom
Verducci senior baseball writers Sports
Illustrated explained the Dodgers
situation obviously injuries are a part
of the three quarters of their infield
is out really miss just in time not just
in the lineup I always thought he's like
parts all that team he makes him go the
great personality but listen the run
score he actually hasn't been that bad
their pitching hasn't been great defense
hasn't been great it's almost time to I
don't want to say panic it's too early
to do that but wonder if that team
didn't make the playoffs
I know you can't really put a division
away in the first month of the season
but you could lose one and you know
Toronto last year was a good example
they were terrible out of the gate and
it played well the last four months or
just got buried in a good division so
listen I don't expect they're gonna
trade for Manny Machado and it's just
they're about resetting their tax rate
when they go out and need to re-sign
Kershaw or go out get Bryce Harper the
tax on that is going to be 20% rather
than 50% that's a huge difference that
multiplies over years so getting the
Channel right now would put them over
the tag I don't see that happening it
also cost their top one or two prospects
they're gonna solve this from within and
by the way I really did like Dave
Roberts oh I love a lot of the
management
calling out Bellinger for lack of hustle
that was not a lack of hustle where you
embarrassed the guy and sit him down
that's a professional 180
was a double all the way if it's
mishandle he's on third base that tells
me there's more than just that one play
going on in that Dodger Clubhouse I've
maintained for the last two years that
Bryce Harper is going to be a four
hundred million dollar player am I am I
too light in that estimate what do you
think he's going to make on the open
market well I'm with you I think the
meter drops to the floor that's where it
starts
I mean when you think about Stanton's
contract you think about that Greinke is
a 32 year-old pitcher getting 33 million
dollars a year on average annual value
this guy's give me a free 18 to 26 on a
Hall of Fame trajectory I mean come on
he's gonna sign for about 11 or 12 years
I do think the number starts with a four
and I also think besides Bryce made a
great player as I said a Hall of Fame
track I think he's what every team would
want in it's an age where he's an
everyday player he's gonna play 80 games
at home rather than start 15 games and
he's a great investment for a franchise
on the field and off the field he's one
of them I want to say three or four
people I don't like you think about this
but three or four people would walk down
the street in any city in America
without his jersey on baseball players
and people know who it is that's got
some value to it I'm not saying that's
why you sign them it's a great player
well you get more what do you think the
Dodgers are going to be all into and
Bryce Harper I don't know I know that
has not been their mo here
I think obviously they have to explore
it you can't rule it out see where it
goes I mean they have to take care of
cursor I would think it's priority
number one
cuz I'm expecting him to opt out and you
certainly want to keep him but no I
don't know that I would say the Dodgers
are sir I wouldn't call him a
front-runner Brandi B's I think they
would get in it see workers Poulos is
approaching 3000 hits who will be the
next to get 3000 hits
it's a good question Anna look to see
who's on the horizon but I think about
Jose Altuve as a guy who's at least
tracking in that direction I mean just
look at his games played I mean that's
become an underrated skill in the game
today where it's about less than guys in
recovery that dude plays every day plays
hard he's racking up his 200 hits every
year he he looks to me like I said this
about Wade Boggs late in his career
people thought is he gonna get there or
not when those guys get in their head
that and Ichiro is the same way if they
want that you're not there 200 hits a
year they want to get 3,000 hits those
single-minded guys are gonna get it and
I see how bad is that kind of plan I
know the number that he's gonna be the
next one but I like his odds Altuve I
think this will be the fifth consecutive
year he'll lead the National League or
the American League in hits or baseball
and hits I think that sounds right
yeah it's crazy - I was looking at this
and we talked about the strikeouts there
are fewer singles in today's games at
any point in baseball history think
about that on a percentage basis it's
harder to get a single one ever before
in history there's now more strikeouts
than hit and now two days like this
throwback player now right hits the ball
all over the field it gets a lot of hits
into your men outfield he's one of my
favorite players just to watch because
he commands your attention anywhere on
the field at any time but my concern
went with watching the game is there
used to be so much movement and that was
there was a base hit or you move the
runner over there now there there's it's
either a strikeout or a home run and
therefore if you're if you're trying to
introduce this game to somebody and get
a new audience you know the home runs
are spectacular but then you're going
maybe there's nothing that happens for
like seven minutes and you know that's
that's where you get instant
gratification with a lot of these other
sports and baseball used to give you
some gratification now it doesn't do
that that's my big concern about this
homerun strikeout situation and that is
movement think about I think there was a
time where you did it nightly highlights
show yes I did right yes I did and say
you're doing a story on Kobe Bryant or
Derek Jeter there used to be just a
still
that athlete behind you on the Chiron
right yeah now you look at any tightest
Jill Nightly News or highlight show
there's movement in the background right
there's some kind of video there's
exciting graphics and that's the way
this we actually have retrained our
brains or if you're young just train
your brains but you crave movement now
and you think about basketball you think
about football with the no heart all you
think about soccer there's movement
across the screen and in baseball you
have now is a static game strikeouts
take a lot of pitches nothing's happened
what was the last time a video of a
strikeout went viral right so that's the
biggest challenge to me that stolen
bases down it's like in the last 50
years
you know the hit and run pretty much
dead the ball is not in play so you
depend on the biggest issue to me it's
not the time of the game it's the lack
of motion and begin yeah if you have
movement then I then I'm not aware of
the time element but I'm aware of the
time element because there's nothing
going on and therefore you can't help
but go what time is it or how long am I
going to stay with this game instead of
saying you know that's great baseball or
you know a sacrifice bunt or a hit and
run or moving the runner over just all
those little things there was movement
even though it might not have seemed
exciting but it did keep your attention
and I think that's what baseball how
they address it I don't know because
we've fallen in love with strikeouts how
hard you throw and then you know how far
you can hit a home run realize that the
way we train pitchers now there's almost
this endless supply of really good
pitchers and that's why you're seeing
four or five six pitchers per night or
just racking up these strikeout I don't
know where that changes safe travels
back Tom thanks for joining us you got
that's Tom Verducci senior baseball
writer for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show at
you